hello everyone
back at the supper suite at South by
Southwest in Austin and we are super
lucky today because we have great
sponsors like blue moon and because of
sponsors like blue moon we could talk
about all these cool movies that we're
seeing at South by including run this
town guys I saw it last night a huge
congratulations to all of you and thank
you for being here today
Thank You Ricky I wanted to start with
you of course because a first feature is
not an easy feat to achieve so I know
you had some producing experience but
can you kind of paint a little picture
of just your background and how the day
came when you said I need to make a
feature was put into commercials we're
gonna fill your Wikipedia page I was on
the back of the phone book across the
country in South Africa and I guess I
liked it I you know I I think I as a kid
I became fascinated with the process of
making movies and telling stories and
when I got into production the producer
of this movie Randy I started interning
for him I was his intern ten years ago
and I told him I think the first week I
was there I was like I want to direct a
movie and he was like why don't you file
some stuff first cool but Randy was
really generous with his time and taught
me about production and about the other
side of putting movies together which I
think came in really handy when I knew
what I wanted my first script to be
because I knew that I wanted to get it
made and I thought there was a way to
make this movie that I wanted to tell so
the production experience in producing
came in handy for me in that way when I
was you know I in some ways I reverse
engineered the script to make sure that
I could get this movie made
just curious now what was point one like
what was one of the biggest things that
you needed to make sure you were able to
do through your scripts in order to get
the green light or the financing you
need because there's also just seems
like a big first feature to like even
the scope feels big to me we shot it in
21 days it's like super super indie but
he made it look like a massive product
like I mean it you did a great job
production value is amazing for really
the budget and it's we're amazing yeah
we had an amazing crew that helped to
put it together and I think it all
starts from character and making sure
that there are characters that speak to
audiences and speak to actors so you can
bring people on that entice people to
see the movie and finance the movie
speaking of the characters just so we
can get a little roll call here and also
just because our viewers probably do not
know what this movie is just yet can
each of you just tell me where your
character fits into the story but I
don't know to spice it up a little they
do they do some good things in the movie
they do some not good things in the
movie what is one admirable quality
about your character that you kind of
want to keep with you I play a character
named Bram Shriver and he is fresh out
of college he's a Jewish boy like myself
and he dreams of being a journalist and
he studied journalism in school and he
gets hired by a fictional paper called
the record in Toronto to be sort of a
low-level reporter writing top ten lists
and best brunch spots and things like
that and then gets involved sort of very
much by chance in a scandal and is able
to sort of sink his teeth into something
a little meteor and I think something
admirable about him would probably be
that he has a real blind ambition and
sort of doesn't listen to for better or
for worse doesn't really take to heart
too much that the people above him sort
of telling him to stay in his place and
really goes sort of goes for the gold
and goes for broke which is great and
certain points in the film and not so
great another you need that blind
ambition if you're gonna take a job that
puts you on the street and make sure you
do man on the street interviews because
that is my first job and it was one of
the most soul-sucking experiences of my
life
and watching that one scene just took me
right back to it I
play a character named Ashley and Ashley
is the only one in the movie that
crosses between both story lines between
Ben's character and he's the journalist
trying to unravel Rob Ford's story and
went in his scandal and then obviously
you know works for Rob Ford and I work
for Rob Ford as well but I cross in
between the two story lines and I the
one redeeming not one what give yourself
more credit one of the redeeming
qualities or positive I just think that
she's a really strong character and she
maybe doesn't know or recognize her
strength at the beginning she's stubborn
and she's in a position that frustrates
her and she has to do and stay in
positions that she wouldn't probably
have stayed in otherwise but because of
circumstance she's forced into a bit of
a corner and then ultimately chooses to
get out of it and find her strength and
act on her her pride her courage she
finds her way and she's kind of a badass
by the end sorry I just watched the
movie for the first time yesterday and
I'm still excited I'm excited about I'm
Hawking that for my follow up question
just watching it for the first time but
Mina can you tell us a little bit about
your character yeah I played kemal I
play Rob Ford's right-hand man and
special assistant the guy who kind of
runs his life and yeah I think he's a
loyal he's a loyal guy and he's
hardworking and everybody has a line so
it's a journey of finding what your line
is but he's loyal and that's something
that I admire about him I thought you
meant lying like a pick-up line everyone
knows a line is come on what's behind
how do you get the ladies know a line
where you call you know you call it
quits or no I got it I got it Scott owe
me I know I play a character named David
I'm an editor at the newspaper where he
works and I'm kind of a
I mean come back to this guy not a lot
of redeeming qualities in fact I've been
sitting here during all these answers
and I can't think of one redeeming
quality what do you think yeah give him
a shot he's a very light on his feet
Grace's Barney really yeah yeah I can't
think of a redeeming quality I mean as
as you clearly had to interview people
for this new position because you wanted
to do less right so in your selfishness
you were selfless by giving him an
opportunity selflessness okay I think
that's maybe you should add a pickup
line for the one thing I really wanted
to ask you guys about because when I was
prepping for this interview I was
googling around and one of the first
things I saw was one of your responses
to a little bit of online criticism and
I was curious to get your take
especially like for the two of you cuz
you've been a part of so many fandoms
and I think those kinds of things have
just been bolstered big time with social
media and just the immediacy of the
Internet so I'm just curious how you
kind of dealt with that while you were
making the movie and what you think the
influence of the internet and social
media is on telling stories like this
where it's the truth and some of it's
also fictionalized as well that's okay I
mean I have certainly dealt with it with
Evan Hansen and and in pitch perfect and
you know there's always something that
people are particularly these days
wanting to really sort of clam on to and
I think you know a lot of intentions are
really good and wanting things to be as
sort of politically correct as they can
be and as and as open as they can be and
as sort of truthful as they can be and
but I think that sort of a general theme
that social media sort of has presented
to us is is taking things at face value
that don't have all the information
quite yet like sort of Ricky put it
really well in an interview earlier
today and saying that a lot of things
are sort of boiled down 240 characters
in the sense that people don't sort of
take the time to to read further into a
story or to get all the details all the
information before making a judgment
call because they're really quick to
sort of wanting to fight for their own
cause whatever that cause may be and so
I think it just falls to us to really
help people be patient and let them see
the story that we're trying to tell and
tell it with all the nuance that we're
trying to tell it with and all the
details we're trying to tell it with
before passing any judgment about who it
represents or doesn't represent or any
sort of political stance it's taking I
think it's difficult to make any comment
on that until you've seen the film
itself or whatever projects you're
talking about are we allowed to drop
mics yeah that was a pretty eloquent
response it's important in this day and
age to do your own investigation into
something because there might not be an
investigation behind 140 character tweet
no matter who it's from and it's
important to get your own facts to know
for yourself you know you could have
your stances on issues but you can't
base your stances on 140 letters there's
definitely that but I also wanted to ask
you in particular why tell this story
with that component because I think true
stories have tons of space that they
should have on the big screen to spread
awareness but I also think that you know
we get a lot of news all the time so in
your movie you have to add more to the
conversation so what was it about these
characters and these elements that you
introduced that you think add to that
story I wanted to tell a story about
people that I knew and I grew up with in
a way that I thought was honest and
wasn't looking at them through
rose-colored glasses and you know it's
my first feature and I wanted it to be
something that I knew deeply and
personally and I think there's a little
bit of me in each of these characters
Bram's experience is very similar to my
brother's experience when he was trying
to become a journalist and he couldn't
he was updating the lower thirds of a
24-hour news stations screen with the
APU newswire overnight after he
graduated from journalism school and
then eventually he was let go to in a
massive layoff from a media company and
it's because journalism isn't the same
as it used to be and I wanted to tell
that story and meet a nina's character
Ashley
he was very much based on a friend of
mine who went to law school and couldn't
get a job as a lawyer when she graduated
she tried really really hard eventually
she found a job in an area of law that
she was not interested in working in for
somebody that she was not comfortable
working for who made her very
uncomfortable but she had student debts
to pay and she felt like she was in a
corner and she didn't have many options
and I wanted to tell that story because
people often asked my friends like why
didn't you just leave the job but it's
not that easy there are shades to every
person and I wanted to tell that story
you know about people that I knew told
it and you told it with a real unique
style to thank you that really it was
just like so in-your-face right at the
beginning and I didn't expect it and it
was a pleasant surprise I have to wrap
up
wait really really really quickly let's
do some let's do some super fast random
questions here they're safe they're fun
pass the mics around please first what
TV show would you love to guest star on
[Music]
10:15 on Hulu marvelous missus Mazal fan
[Laughter]
I'm on thanks for being supportive
I don't know but reprise on who loose
coming out soon and I think you should a
whole that's it good it's so crazy that
you say that's actually the show called
the politician that's also coming out of
Netflix that I heard is actually pretty
good
there might be something called Aladdin
that people should watch - May 24th 2019
yes that's coming out as well
24th 21st is the premiere though but I
don't think I'll be able to get you a
ticket
what line of movie dialogue do you quote
the most did we just become best friends
Jhansi yeah your minds will fail - I'm
in a glass case of emotion that's a good
one thank you I'll go for him can I go
for you I feel like this one would have
been yours anyway grew up watching only
like a number of movies but Li what the
hell wrong with you man that's Chris
Tucker and Russia our last one here I
want to ask so many well there's like I
quote something all the time and I
actually have no idea if it's real or if
I my friend and I know that we heard it
somewhere in a movie or a television
show and we don't know what it is so
anybody knows where this is from please
let us know it's just well I'm here and
you're here and there's no and you fill
in the blank cuz I think it's and
there's no car or and there's no food or
something like that but I don't know
what I feel like you're
reverse-engineering another movie here
alright one more let's go with what's
the worst job you've ever had
I worked in a grocery store in Markham
Ontario and I was the shelf boy and I
couldn't even do that because I got
fired I've had a lot of insane jobs but
I guess the worst out of all of them was
overnight Baker I did it for two nights
I couldn't handle it then I would then I
did room service after that I worked my
first job was as a it was a paper engine
paper routes except I was like five and
my brother was ten and I didn't realize
that I was doing child labor and I was
doing his job and he was getting paid
for it but I thought it was like bonding
brother-sister time and really he was
just making me do his work well he got
you think oh wow
dark I liked the job itself I was a camp
counselor for a Tijera summer camp but
the part of it that I really didn't like
was having to I had a kid who was really
behaviorally really difficult and we had
to make sort of the group decision as a
staff that he couldn't really stay at
camp and we had to break it in that he
had to go home and I was really relieved
thing to do as a counselor the person
yeah but it was sad because I wanted it
to work out but it just sometimes you
can't he had no ability to respect
authority and say he's doing fine now
that he came back the next number I was
a janitor in a school for a shut yeah
imagine this guy being a janitor Wow
that was very bad ending no I mean they
were there was during the summer like
that the school look they say but now
that was my really only job I've never
really had you guys got one of the best
jobs in the world here thank you so much
for spending time with us today huge
congratulations on the movie guys that
run this town check it out keep an eye
out for it from the supper suite here in
Austin thank you so much for watching
we'll see you soon
you